AMIT SINGHAL: I
can't hear you, man.
How's everyone doing?
So, I'll let you in on a secret.
For 40 years, 40
years, I've been
trying to learn how to dance.
Every teacher I
hired, quit on me.
So I decided to hire
the best in the world.
So, everyone, with loud,
thunderous applause,
please welcome my new dance
teacher, Madhuri Dixit-Nene.
Clearly these two
need no introduction,
but let me just
remind you-- for some
of those who are a bit
younger than I am, OK?
So Madhuri is clearly one of
the most popular leading actress
in Indian cinema, known for
her powerful performances
and amazing dance skills
that you just saw.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE: Thank you.
AMIT SINGHAL: She
wowed audiences
in classic films like, "Tezaab,"
"Ram Lakhan," "Saajan,"
"Hum Aapke Hain Koun!"
and many, many more.
Six film theater awards grace
her mantlepiece at the house.
And that's out of a
16 record nomination
that she got in
Film Theater awards
and that's just the
Film Theater awards.
Let me just read a list
of awards she has won.
Pretty much anything that
you can win in Indian cinema,
Madhuri has won
them, and that's why
I need the paper,
because I won't
be able to remember those.
So Madhuri has won Kalabhinetri
award, Platinum Diva Award,
Screen Award, "Vogue"
Bollywood Beauty Legend Award--
right guys?-- Zee Cine
Award, just to name a few.
And to top it all off, she
was awarded the Padma Shri,
one of the highest
civilian honors
by the government
of India in 2008.
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE: Thank you.
AMIT SINGHAL: She's also a
UNICEF Goodwill Ambassador,
and her husband is an
accomplished cardiothoracic
surgeon, Dr. Shriram Nene.
Now, Ram is a product of some
of the top cardiac schools
in the country, Washington
University and UCLA,
and practiced for over
a decade before moving
to India with Madhuri and
their two lovely sons.
Together, they started
Dance with Madhuri,
an initiative to
help teach everyone
in the world about
dance, and want
to expand it to include
music, acting, and medicine.
I've known both
of them put a bit,
and there is one thing, for
which they do not give out
an award, but if they
did, Ram and Madhuri
would win it, hands down,
every year of their lives.
And that one thing is humility.
They both have hearts
of gold, and they
have filled their lives with
family, love, selflessness,
and, yes, humility.
Madhuri and Ram, it's
a joy to welcome you
to the Google stage.
SHRIRAM NENE: Thank
you very much, Amit.
It's our pleasure to be here.
Amit and I spent a bit of
time together last summer,
which he may or may not
have told you about.
We did a 6-day trek
in Ladakh, and we
start at about 9,000
feet and went all the way
to 17,500 feet.
And this was the sort of trek
that humbles any one of us,
and this guy was like Iron Man.
He came in-- flew in at
the last minute, on Diamox,
and the rest of us were
all having our vasodilation
headaches.
And, I mean, you can imagine
walking between 10 and 15 miles
a day at that altitude.
It really tests you.
And the bottom line
is having friends
like him is what matters
in anyone's lifetime,
and that's what makes it full.
And so it's an absolute
pleasure to be here
amongst friends and family.
And we are really
looking forward to this.
AMIT SINGHAL: Thank you,
Ram, for the kind words.
OK, now you all guys, be
nice to me in the future, OK?
Madhuri, when you started
on the Bollywood scene,
you were known for
your dance style.
How long have you been dancing?
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE: Well,
I have been dancing ever
since I was three years old.
I'm classically trained.
I've learned kathak.
That's an old Indian style
of classical dancing.
Yes, woo!
I love that style.
I really love that
style, because I
feel once you learn kathak,
you can do any style
in the world-- which I have
done through my movies.
I am a very, very
passionate actress.
It's my first love, acting,
but dance has always
been my passion.
I've grown up dancing.
So even when I did my films, I
try to do some extra, you know,
that add a little
bit of extra with me
and Saroji, the choreographer.
Yes, everybody knows about her.
We formed a lovely
team, and we work
so well together because we were
both passionate about dancing.
And we wanted to take
Indian film dancing
to a different level.
And that's what our goal
used to be every time we
did a song together.
AMIT SINGHAL: Awesome.
So what drew you to dance?
Was it instant when you
were, like, three years old?
I mean, like, this
is what I want to do.
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE: It
came-- I don't know-- to me,
it came naturally.
I just was attracted to dance.
And I think it's everything.
Dance, to me, is everything,
because it keeps you fit,
it makes you feel good, it
makes your soul feel good,
and it's just-- it's a
beautiful way to express.
AMIT SINGHAL: And there are lots
of parents into the audience
here, who are probably putting
their kids in dance school,
right now.
What advice would both of you
have for those parents here?
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE: Well, I
would say, go to your computers
and Google us.
Dance with Madhuri
is my website,
and you can go on that.
You can take a look.
There are so many
different styles
we are teaching on
this site, and I
think what is so important is
to see what your kid takes to.
A child has to take to a
certain style of dancing.
And they will just know
it within their souls
that this is what I want to do,
or that is what I want to do.
And let them follow their
heart, because if they
do something they
love, they'll really,
really give it their all.
All the styles are there under
one roof on Dance with Madhuri.
So I would first like them
to try it out, and see,
and select which dance
they would like to learn.
They can learn it
on the website,
or they can go to a
school and learn it.
SHRIRAM NENE: I think, to add
one thing to that-- dance,
to me, is about happiness,
confidence, and health.
And what it epitomizes
is a holistic way to,
kind of, take care of yourself.
It becomes a metaphor
for life in some regards.
So when we put this
project together,
quite an interesting journey,
in that, as some of you know,
I grew up here.
And I had done some
software entrepreneur work
at the age of 14,
and had a company.
And my Indian parents
said you either
become a doctor or engineer,
or we won't pay for it.
Does that sound
familiar to you guys?
AMIT SINGHAL: Yes.
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE:
And so, the thing
was, being the dutiful
son, I became a doctor,
and I became a heart
surgeon, and I really loved
my career-- very rewarding,
took care of some amazing people
in very difficult times.
But my problem was
I couldn't scale it.
No matter how hard I worked--
300 to 500 patients per year.
And the issue for
me was that there's
7 billion people on the planet.
So the journey I
made was that, if I
could take my original skills
combined with her media talent,
and then amalgamate them
with brick-and-mortar,
we could change the way
people think about medicine.
And we move to India in
2011-- kind of a bold thing.
You can imagine
my parents' face.
What are you doing?
You are the head of a hospital.
You are a partner in a group.
You've been practicing
for 10 years,
and you do 300 to
500 cases a year.
And you're just abandoning all
that to go and start a start-up
or something like that?
I don't know, it's a journey
many of you might have made
or will make at some
point in your life,
but daunting nevertheless.
And so then during the course, I
was building out the healthcare
constructs, and one
day she said to me
that culture, as we
know it, is changing.
And I learned dance and
acting, because I loved it.
It was passionate.
And what ended up
happening was, now,
in the cinemas and other things,
it's a lot of commercialism.
She's like, if I
could teach this,
I could change the
way people think.
And I'm like, well, you're
facing the same problems
that I am that we
can't scale it.
So what if we put a team
on this and scaled it?
And what ended up
happening was three
months of rapid prototyping and
engineering, launched in 2013,
didn't know if it would work.
And what we ended
up finding out is
that people could
learn remotely,
and they could extend their
level, and move forward.
So the idea is to build a
global village for culture,
where everyone is equal.
And I think the last thought
is, genius exists in everyone.
The standardized tests
don't examine it.
And the problem is
there's a lot of people
on the planet who don't have
the opportunities that we do.
And so the idea is if you
can take this out to them,
and find them, and nurture
that kernel of genius
into a full-grown plan, you
will change the way people think
and how things happen.
So her love of dance
kind of spurned this,
and it became a
platform, and it grew.
And so I'll show you
some of that later.
AMIT SINGHAL: Great,
thank you, Rob.
That's great.
So as you said, you were raised
here, and I know for a fact
that before you met
Madhuri, you did not
follow Indian cinema very much.
OK?
So what happened, dude?
When someone mentioned
Madhuri for the first time,
did you run to your
computer and Google her?
SHRIRAM NENE: That's a good
way to set it up there.
You know, I might have.
I don't know.
The thing is, my
folks are from Mumbai,
and I can only speak Marathi.
I didn't speak Hindi,
and so we hadn't grown up
watching Hindi cinema.
And the other thing
was, I was at UCLA,
and so we took care of a lot
of the Hollywood industry.
And I'll be very
candid with you.
The industry there
is completely crazy.
I mean, the types
of people you meet--
The last thing I want to do is
see someone in the industry.
But then I met her
brother, and he
was phenomenal, very
down-to-earth, very grounded,
and kind of fit our,
sort of, overall mindset
and agreed to meet her.
And I think I probably might
have Googled her back then,
or Yahooed her, or something.
AMIT SINGHAL: He just
doesn't want to admit it, OK?
SHRIRAM NENE: No, no,
I'm giving them that.
AMIT SINGHAL: It's cool,
we all know how it works.
It's OK.
SHRIRAM NENE: Yeah, and
the rest is history.
And there you have it.
AMIT SINGHAL: So
Madhuri, how was it
leaving Mumbai,
Bollywood, and coming here
and living in Denver--
rather cold compared
to Mumbai-- for over a decade?
How was it for you?
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE: Yeah,
you know, in Mumbai it's
hot, hotter, and hottest.
For the first time, I saw
snow, and cold, and fall,
and all the four seasons.
And it was beautiful.
I mean, Denver is a beautiful
place to live for anyone.
You walk out, and everything
that I had never found
in Mumbai I got in Denver.
It was pleasing to the eyes,
the air is so beautiful,
and the mountains all around--
a very beautiful place.
You know, in life,
everybody has dreams, right?
You have goals.
You have dreams.
And having a
family, having kids,
was a big part of my dream,
not just my profession,
and being an actress,
and everything else.
But, for me, this was
a big, big deal for me.
Because I grew up
in a big family.
We have four siblings.
And so, for me, having kids
was very, very important.
Having a husband,
a home, and that
was a big part of my dream.
Of course, I wanted 12
children at one point,
when I was a little bit--
But after I had two,
I was like, yeah,
this is good enough.
I mean, that's how
I enjoyed myself.
I kind of throw myself
into everything I do,
whether it was looking
after my kids or my home,
or living that life,
going out shopping.
It gave me a sense of freedom.
Because in Mumbai,
if I go shopping,
there are like 10 people
around me, you know.
And I was never left
alone, basically.
But here, I remember
the first time
I went out to just grocery shop,
I had to take my car and go
and my heart was
just like, pumping.
It was like, boom,
boom, boom, boom,
boom-- as if I'm
trying to do something
that I've never done before.
But it just freed me.
It gave a sense of freedom.
And for me, life is not all
about just my profession
or just acting, or just dancing.
It's the experiencing
every day, you know,
the different kind of things
you have to go through,
the situations and how you
deal with them, and the life
lessons.
And I love to live
my life, basically.
And so, that's what was
most attractive about it.
AMIT SINGHAL: Wonderful,
that's so wonderful.
Yes.
We're talking about movies.
You've done, like,
70-plus movies.
How many?
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE: 78-plus.
AMIT SINGHAL: 78-plus movies.
Yes.
Is there a favorite one for you?
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE: You
know, everybody asks me that,
but-- It's a very
cliched answer.
So, people may say, oh, you're
very diplomatic, but it's true.
Because every movie
we do, there's
a little bit of me in the movie.
But if you put a gun to
my head and said, no, you
have to say one movie,
which you've really enjoyed,
I would say, I enjoy
doing that movie
because we were a lot
of actors together
at every point in the
movie-- 12 of us, six of us.
And we really had
fun making the movie.
Also it talked about
all of the values
that I believe in-- family,
and an extended family,
and everybody living
together in peace,
and harmony, and all that.
And it would be "Hum Aapke
Hain Koun!" obviously.
AMIT SINGHAL: All right.
So after that question,
here's a two-part question.
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE: Two part?
AMIT SINGHAL: It's
a two-part question.
Part one, is there
ever pizza and movie
night at the home when
you put in a Madhuri movie
and all of you watch it?
Number two, when you do do
that, or when your kids do watch
a Madhuri movie, how
judgmental are they
about your performance?
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE: I'll just
tell you one little incident.
As I was leaving home, my
kids were watching cable,
and one of my movies
was on, "Koyla."
And they were like,
sitting in front of the TV,
and I'm like, OK,
I'm out of here.
I'm leaving.
And I left.
And I came back in the
evening, and on the computer,
on one of my kids'
computers, there
was a little note hanging
there which said, Mom.
And I'm like, what's this?
So I just picked it up.
And it was, "Dear Mom, Why are
you acting so funny in "Koyla?"
Love, Aaron."
So, for them, it's like,
you know, it varies.
Their reaction varies.
And I remember in Gulaab
Gang, there is this one short
where I raise my hand, and
then I'm like the big boss,
and I'm doing this.
And my kids saw it
and just freaked out.
And they were doing
variations of that.
People were walking like a duck,
you know, and doing all that.
So nobody takes me
seriously in my family.
That's what I'm trying to say.
SHRIRAM NENE: I think
the other comment to make
is, we don't wear
stars on our shoulders.
And when we go home,
all of that turns off.
In fact, all of the trophies
that you're talking about
are all in the office.
We don't allow them at home.
We don't watch her films.
I mean, I've only
seen like a handful
since we've been married, mainly
because of the Hindi issue.
Now I speak Hindi,
but the issue is,
I think it's about being
grounded and not getting
caught up in your careers.
I mean, whether it's a heart
surgeon, or an actress,
or anything else,
that's just a job.
You're passionate
about what you do,
but it's the holistic
kind of balance
that you strike in your life.
And just remember that
you're very fortunate--
and every one of us
is in this room--
and there's a lot of
people who don't have that.
So the idea is to think of
others when you do stuff,
and to do it for those reasons,
rather than for yourself.
Although we're very
passionate about what we do,
regardless of what it is.
But I would say the movie nights
are generally the Transformers
or something like
that with the boys,
and just hanging out
and having some fun.
AMIT SINGHAL: So how's
the move to India been?
I think it's been amazing.
I mean, India has
changed dramatically.
My in-laws-- I'm
sorry, my family
came from Dadar in
Mumbai, if you guys
have been to Mumbai at all.
And I would go back
there every summer
to hang out with my
grandma and grandpa.
So I'd been there and seen
it change over 40 years.
If you go there now-- not just
Mumbai, but Dehli, Bangalore,
any of these cities-- it's
come in such a direction.
And I don't know if you
call it forward, sideways,
upside down, whatever.
But, I mean, it's becoming a
Western culture very quickly.
And they have some significant
issues they grapple with,
and yet the culture
is so beautiful.
I call Mumbai my
Manhattan of sorts,
because you can get
food any time of day.
The people are very warm.
And there are
different struggles.
I mean, traffic is the same
everywhere, I found out today.
And it was the same.
It was the same in LA,
the same in Mumbai,
and whatnot-- just
variations on the theme.
But I think, overall, it's
been an amazing experience.
And I would recommend, if you
guys get some time-- I mean,
a lot of you guys, I
see in the audience,
are from India, originally.
And so you understand it.
But I think it's so
rapidly changing.
And, I mean, this new
prime minister and whatnot
is bringing us in a direction,
which is unfathomed.
And even in the last 10
years, the number of advances
are amazing.
AMIT SINGHAL: Cool.
So that's great.
Now, you moved back to
India, and the first question
my daughter had for
me was, does she
go to [INAUDIBLE] herself now?
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE: Uh.
I think it's back
to square one now.
I have to pick and choose where
I can be or where I can go.
But I do try.
Because after living in Denver
and after being so independent,
then you go back, and everything
is a little different then.
Because when you live there,
you take everything for granted.
You know, oh my maid is going
to go and get this, that.
But now, when you've lived by
yourself and done everything,
it's like, I want to
go, but how do I do it?
So then I wear my
hat or my big gold
glares, or something like that.
And I feel, oh, this
is the proper disguise.
Nobody's going to look at me.
And when you're buying
your veggies or whatever,
and then somebody
comes in and whispers,
can I have an autograph, please?
Oh, I failed again.
But, yes, I do try to do that.
It's a little limited,
but I still try.
SHRIRAM NENE: I would say
the truth is this, right?
There's not many places
she can go in public.
Me, on the other hand, I'll
go by train, I'll go by bus,
and my people will say,
no, you can't do that.
It never really
bothered me, right?
I grow up in the US.
The hardest part for me is that
I can't change a light bulb
without someone saying, no,
you've got to call this person
or do this.
I'm like, really, come on.
I grew up in the US.
We did everything for ourselves.
And so it's been that way
a little bit of a change,
but for her-- I mean, in the US,
she would put together the Ikea
furniture and the other
stuff we'd got and--
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE:
I love to do that.
SHRIRAM NENE: She loved it.
Yeah, exactly.
AMIT SINGHAL: And from
what little I know,
she was much better
at it than Ran.
OK?
SHRIRAM NENE: Not true.
AMIT SINGHAL: So let's talk
about Dance with Madhuri now.
You're trying to build
a community of artists,
of dancers, people who
love dancing, people
who want to learn dancing.
Where did the idea come from?
Where do you want to take it?
SHRIRAM NENE: The thing is, I
kind of hinted at this earlier,
every single one of us has a
little genius in them, right?
And it just dawned
on us that what
if Pablo Picasso never got his
pencil, or pen, or paintbrush?
What if Marie Curie never got
an opportunity to go and learn?
And what if Einstein
never had an opportunity
to write his thesis?
And then think, how
many people in the world
never have that opportunity?
And so, for me, I started
out with this health
construct to take good
evidence-based medicine
to everyone on the planet.
Because what I
saw was that there
were a lot of people
who weren't getting
the opportunities that all
of us have in this room
and in the US.
And even in the US,
for that matter,
when I was practicing
several years ago,
38 million people
never had insurance.
And the idea is that medicine
is one of those things
that everyone should have,
but it went further than that.
And what it became
was a platform
where we could experiment,
and we could teach people
in a fun and social manner.
So this is one of those things
where if you gameify learning,
you can change the
way people learn.
I remember learning when I
was growing up that it was
all rote summarization, right?
You must learn this, and
then throw it up on the test,
and you will do well.
But my feeling is that really
leaves out the bell curve,
right?
The ends of it.
And so what we've done is tried
to make it fun and social.
At the same time, we've
taken dance, in particular,
and used it to stay fit.
So I put a fitness band
on her, and in 15 minutes,
her heart rate
sustained was 130 to 160
and her caloric burn
was 400 calories.
So we put that on
our YouTube channel--
just wanted to put
that plug in there--
and we had like 175 hours
of viewing per month.
It became, like, our
number-one most-viewed thing.
And so what we found is people
we're learning, certainly,
but they were using dance
as a means to work out.
And, if you think about it,
what would you rather do?
Be on a treadmill
looking at a TV
or whatever, or have some
beautiful woman in front
of you, taking you
through the moves
and losing calories
in 15 minutes?
And then what we did was
we knit that together
with a social network
and a marketplace.
So now when these people learn,
they're not just learning,
but they're creating
video resumes.
And what they're
doing is essentially
becoming marketable.
So what we're doing is
we're discovering talent
from all over the planet,
not just from one area.
I would love to cue that
one video, if we have it,
on the [INAUDIBLE] piece.
AMIT SINGHAL: All right, guys.
Can we cue the video please?
SHRIRAM NENE: I think this
tells the story very nicely.
So, all in all, it became a
passion play, in that, what
could we do to change
people's lives?
And dance was really
the tip of the iceberg,
because if you take
this and build it out
to the other verticals, it
becomes incredibly [INAUDIBLE].
Here you go.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
AMIT SINGHAL: Here's the video.
SHRIRAM NENE: So this
is an average lesson.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-So before we actually
start the lesson,
I want you to get familiar
with some of the hand mudras.
Your right hand with the
lotus, and the other hand
is like a deer hand.
1, 2, 3.
So you're curling your
hands [INAUDIBLE] style.
OK, so this is the sign, or the
hook, or the signature step.
Chen, god will be separate.
Rhada, rhada, rhada, rah.
[END PLAYBACK]
AMIT SINGHAL: So
speaking of dance, Ram,
could you dance
before you met her?
SHRIRAM NENE: Yeah, I could
cut a rug, but not like after.
I mean, some of the
parties we've gone to,
and some of the things she's
taught me, it's another world.
AMIT SINGHAL: And are
you any better now?
SHRIRAM NENE: I would say so.
Can you answer that?
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE: Yeah.
I mean-- [AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
We were at this party, and
you know, they were like,
oh, you have to dance.
Doctor Nene, you've got to
dance, dance, and everybody
was insisting.
And there was [INAUDIBLE],
and there was [INAUDIBLE], and
[? Farah, ?] and everyone.
AUDIENCE: Woo!
SHRIRAM NENE: You
know, yeah, woo!
Who said that?
So all of them, and
I had to grab him
and say, OK, you got
to dance on the floor.
And he was like, oh, my god!
I'm like, we were
shooting for all this,
and I think he's picked
up a lot, just watching.
And he was so good on the floor
that [? Farah ?] came up to me
and says, he's going to be
my next dance partner, now.
So yeah, I, mean he is free of
spirit, and he loves to learn,
and he's very observant.
And whenever we were doing
classes, or whatever--
by the way, he's also done
one of the classes where,
it's called "Dance
for the Non-Dancer"--
so his training started there.
AMIT SINGHAL: I will take that.
I will take that, yeah.
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE: And I
think you should try it, too.
AMIT SINGHAL: Yes, thank you.
SHRIRAM NENE: I think
it's infectious.
You know?
I mean, you see these
people, and it's just,
as they say, poetry
in motion or fluid.
And it really kind of
drives you after a while.
I mean, there's a lot
of things that do,
but there's different
types of art.
This is one of those things
that really makes it happiness.
AMIT SINGHAL: Cool.
So in a minute I'm
going to open it up
to the audience for questions.
If you have a question
for Madhuri and Ram,
please get to one of these mics.
You know the TGIF routine.
SHRIRAM NENE: I was going to
make just one comment, two
comments, actually.
The one is it's free.
And our goal is to
keep it free forever,
so that there's
absolutely no impediments
or obstacles to the end user.
The second is, all of
the greatest artists
are coming on the
platform, whether it's
Birju Maharaj, Saroj
Kahn, Terrence, Remo,
and a host of [INAUDIBLE]
and other choreographers.
The idea is to create
one place where everyone
can go and feel free to add
and subtract and bring everyone
together.
And the idea was literally
global village for culture.
And so that's the
idea behind it.
AMIT SINGHAL: OK,
before I open it up.
One question.
What's that one piece of
technology that you guys can't
live without?
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE: At my
house, we cannot live without
technology.
There has to be a gadget for
everything in the house, right?
Yeah,
SHRIRAM NENE: Pretty much.
AMIT SINGHAL: I know, but that's
like, "I love all my children"
answer.
All right?
That's what a guy's supposed
to give as an answer.
OK?
Now, someone put
a gun to your head
and said, what's the
one piece of technology?
AUDIENCE: IPhone.
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE:
Oh, my goodness, yes.
iPhone.
Easily.
Yeah.
[AUDIENCE BOOS]
SHRIRAM NENE: All right,
all right, all right.
Hang on, hang on, hang on.
I'm going to show you some love.
I've got my Android phone.
[AUDIENCE CHEERS]
And actually, I'll just
tell you one other thing.
I've got Dance
with Madhuri on it.
It actually runs
better than my iPhone.
So try it.
AMIT SINGHAL: Oh,
that's so awesome.
Now, we asked people who
couldn't get in today,
to submit a bunch of
questions for you.
And let me start asking
some of those questions
that people have
submitted for you.
Now, many of us who came
to the US as adults,
have found the social anonymity
of not being known by anybody
something to adjust to.
In your case, the feeling
must have been far greater.
Did you welcome that change?
If not, how did
you deal with it?
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE: Yeah,
it was a welcome change.
Because when you're, like,
famous or a celebrity in India,
there's not much you can do.
and.
The way I worked, for me life
was just from one studio,
to another, to
another, to another.
And I really didn't get to
live life normally, you know,
like how everybody lives.
They go out with your
friends, the college friends,
and I started really early.
I started when I was 16.
So I missed out on that, and,
not that I'm complaining,
but that's the life I knew.
And when I moved
to Denver, it was,
like I said, a freedom for me.
Because suddenly I was free to
do anything that I wanted to.
I could go to the grocery shop.
I didn't have to dress
up or do anything.
I could just go the way I
was, and I could get grocery,
I could take my kids
out, go to the park,
just enjoy everything.
And another part of
it is when I met Ram.
He was into adventure
sports, and he
used to do all kinds of crazy
stuff, which I had never
done in my life.
I'm a very careful
person, very protected,
and I just knew that
I was an actress
and I went from one
studio to another,
and I danced, and sang,
and acted, and everything.
But this was like freedom.
I was outdoors.
The first day after we met, he
said, let's go mountain biking.
And I'm like, yeah.
And I had not ridden
a bike in 20 years.
I had done it when I was
little, and I had not.
And I thought, mountain
biking is just taking a bike
and going on a mountain, right?
How can that be?
And I went with him, it was
like, whoa, I was coming down,
like, rocky things.
And I was like,
did I just do that?
At some poor spots, I was like,
I don't think I can do this.
And he was like, why?
Because I haven't
done this in 20 years.
So he was like, you
cannot mountain bike?
And I said, no.
So there were some portions
where he had to carry my bike,
and we just walked
across and did all that.
But it just gave me a sense
of freedom, just showed me
another life altogether,
and I've really, really
enjoyed every moment of it.
AMIT SINGHAL: That's so joyful.
Let's take the first
question, please.
AUDIENCE: Hello, Madhuri.
Hello, Dr. Nene.
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE: Hello.
SHRIRAM NENE: Hi.
How are you?
AUDIENCE: First,
complement first.
Madhuri, you are great,
amazing gift to this universe.
It's really, really amazing.
And here, I was not
listening anything.
I was just staring you,
because this is the first time
I'm seeing you in person.
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have two questions.
One two Madhuri,
and one to Dr. Nene.
Madhuri, how does feel
like being Madhuri?
Like, do you see, like,
something special?
Or, like, it's kind
of god gift, right?
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE: I know,
let's put it this way,
that you guys make
me feel special.
AUDIENCE: OK.
How does that love
feel around you?
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE:
Yeah, there's
a lot of love around
me, and I know
everybody's looking
at me very lovingly,
and it makes me feel special.
It makes me feel special,
but I don't know.
I am just a very happy person.
I am very positive in life.
And when I look at
something, I see life,
you know, like the glass
half full not half empty.
So I just enjoy every
moment in my life,
and I don't think
too much about that.
I don't think about the fact
that I'm Madhuri or whatever.
I'm just a person who
loves doing things,
and I want to share
that with my fans now.
Because I love dancing so much,
I want to share that with them.
And so, that's how I look at it.
AUDIENCE: What's
the one thing you
want to give it to the
world other than dancing?
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE: I
think joy, happiness, just
feel good about themselves.
That's something I would
really love to give back.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
Question to Dr. Nene is,
what was your first reaction
when you met Madhuri?
SHRIRAM NENE: I don't
know what to say.
I didn't know who she was.
AMIT SINGHAL: He was speechless,
that's what he's saying.
SHRIRAM NENE: Yeah, that.
AMIT SINGHAL: This
man will never learn.
I've tried teaching him, OK?
SHRIRAM NENE: I've been
married long enough,
probably it doesn't matter.
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE: Now
I make him speechless.
I don't let him talk.
SHRIRAM NENE: Exactly.
What?
No, but what you find-- so
there's a couple of points.
The first is, I grew up in LA.
I was surrounded
by the industry.
And so what you found
is, they put their pants
on one leg at a time,
just like everyone else.
And the issue is
that-- the connect
was that we didn't treat each
other different, regardless
of what our stature
was, what we did.
And the one thing
I loved about her
was that she's down
to earth, and very,
very straightforward and
focused, and no nonsense,
and that's not always the
case in the filmy line.
I'll tell you that.
I think you can answer that.
And so we are kind of the
un-filmy people, in that we're
real, and we like
to stay that way.
And you won't see us going
out and doing crazy stuff.
I mean, that's fun
once in awhile.
But the bottom line is that
it has to be a balance.
And so the answer
is, she was real.
That's what mattered to me.
And certainly with my career and
her career, the other comment
someone had asked, I think,
was the anonymity factor.
She's the one person who's
been everywhere and yet been
nowhere.
And what I mean by that is,
they closed the Eiffel Tower
for one of her shoots.
And, imagine that, the Eiffel
Tower-- the [INAUDIBLE],
everything else.
They went to a
glacier in Alaska,
had multiple chopper setups,
and shooting for a movie
called "Pukar," and
yet, for these guys,
it's a matter of jetting in,
getting in hair and makeup,
putting on your clothes,
and jetting out.
So in the time we've been
married, the one kind of gift
was that we could go
and do things normally.
And the US kind
of afforded that,
in that she could
actually go out and drive
to Whole Foods or whatever
and buy groceries.
Which that doesn't
sound like a lot.
It sounds like a
chore to most people,
but for someone like
this, it's like freedom.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I can imagine.
AMIT SINGHAL: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And I really
want to thank Google
for organizing this.
Thank you.
AMIT SINGHAL: Thank you.
Let's take the next question.
AUDIENCE: Hello, guys.
So Madhuri, at what
point in your career
did you realize-- maybe were
you reflecting at some point--
that you had make it?
Cause there are a lot of men and
women in India and everywhere
in the world, who want
to be where you are.
And when did you feel,
yes, I've done it?
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE:
My film called
"Tezaab" was released
in '89, and I
remember I was not in
India when it released.
I was here in the US.
And I was in Washington,
or Chicago, I think,
because my sister
was getting married.
And my agent at that point
had called me, and he said,
[NON-ENGLISH] picture,
[NON-ENGLISH].
Like that.
And I had never had a hit film,
so for me, it was like, oh,
good.
I have a hit film now.
It's a hit.
It's a success.
And so I was very
happy about that,
but I'd never faced recognition
before when I was working.
Oh, once in awhile, maybe.
But I had landed at
the airport, and there
was these two little
kids, you know,
who come in and kind of
wipe your car sometimes.
So they were looking at me,
and suddenly one of them says,
Are you the [NON-ENGLISH] girl?
I said, Yeah.
Can we have an autograph?
And I was so thrilled--
signing an autograph
and somebody's recognized me.
And I signed my name, and
I wrote Madhuri Dixit,
and I gave it to him.
And he turns to the other
guy and says, [NON-ENGLISH].
So, yeah, that was the
first time I thought,
oh my goodness, I made it.
AMIT SINGHAL: OK.
Let's take the next
question over there.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my
name is Kanubria.
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE: Hello.
AUDIENCE: First of all, I
still feel I am dreaming.
I cannot believe you are
watching me right now.
So I have two questions.
The first is about
Dance with Madhuri.
I've never danced
in my entire life,
and it's probably because
of that inhibition
that you were talking about.
And that has grown
so much that I'm not
at all comfortable dancing.
So how would Dance with
Madhuri help, and what advice
do you have for people like me?
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE:
Well, Dance with Madhuri
is something you can do in your
own time, in your own space.
You could be in your own
room in front of a computer.
Nobody's watching you.
And it's just the teacher
in front of you and you.
And I think somewhere it'll
help you get away inhibitions,
because nobody's
watching you do that.
And with Dance with Madhuri,
you can rewind it 20,000 times
and see it again,
and again, and again,
which a school
doesn't afford you.
Because once you go there, the
class is just for one hour.
You come home, and you
have to basically work
where your memory-- you know,
wherever your memory is good,
that's what you will remember.
But with this, you can
practice in your own time,
in your own space.
And every little lesson is
split into 15-seconders.
So they will teach you
step-by-step every little
thing.
And I think it'll be
easier to learn that way.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AMIT SINGHAL: Let's take the
next question over there.
I'm keeping time.
I want lots of people
to ask questions.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thank you.
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE: I
hope that answers you.
AUDIENCE: Yes, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Madhuri.
You've got an enigmatic smile.
You're a fantastic dancer and
definitely a fabulous artist.
I mean, we're all graced here.
My question to Mr.
Nene is, you were
walking down the aisle with
the heartthrob of India, right?
All the men-- How many
letters and emails
did you get from all the men
from India, grabbing this lady?
SHRIRAM NENE: I don't
remember much of that.
It was my chief resident year
at UCLA in general surgery,
and we didn't get a
whole lot of sleep.
Fortunately, there was
a good PR core there.
And they would protect me.
But once in awhile
on rounds, someone
would surprise you
and say, hey, are you
this person or that person?
And that was new for me.
And so I didn't
really live in that.
I mean, we were
kind of insulated.
Our agents everyone set up--
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE: He didn't
know what he was getting into.
SHRIRAM NENE: In short.
SHRIRAM NENE: Next question.
I'm sorry, I'll have to
make that the last question.
Over there.
AUDIENCE: Which-- Hi, Madhuri.
Apurna, biggest [INAUDIBLE].
Who among the following is the
best dancer according to you?
A, Hrithik Roshan, B, Salman
Khan, C, Govinda, D, Prabhu
Deva?
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE: Oh, my god.
AMIT SINGHAL: [NON-ENGLISH].
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE: Yeah.
The thing is that all of these
guys are such a good dancers,
but, of course, if you take
the whole, like package,
I would say-- No,
not in that sense.
[LAUGHTER]
Wrong word to use.
SHRIRAM NENE: Gotta be
careful around here.
MADHURI DIXIT
NENE: Yeah, I know.
I know.
If you take the whole, uh,
personality and everything.
I think that's a better word.
It would be Hrithik Roshan.
Because I think,
[WHISTLES AND CHEERS] yeah.
Because when he dances, it's
like, he just mesmerizes you.
SHRIRAM NENE: I would say
Prabhu Deva, by a long stretch.
He's like on fire.
He has no bones,
literally, no bones.
The guy can twist
and do anything.
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE:
Yeah, I remember
doing "Que Sera Sera" with him.
So that was quite a tough song.
AMIT SINGHAL: So,
I tell you a story.
Ram and I were hiking
for six days in Ladakh.
And six days are a long time.
Periodically, we'll get bored.
And whenever I got
bored, I made Ram
sing one of those Hindi
songs of hers, OK?
And with Ram's Hindi, I would
be entertained for hours.
So Ram, would you
please do us the honor?
SHRIRAM NENE: No, no.
AMIT SINGHAL: Yes!
And we are going
[INAUDIBLE] for you, OK?
All right, guys, let's give
Ram a big round of applause.
Let's go!
SHRIRAM NENE: I don't know.
So what are we singing?
AMIT SINGHAL: Whatever you like.
One of her songs.
SHRIRAM NENE: Never fails
to put me on the spot here.
Last time--
AMIT SINGHAL:
[INAUDIBLE] is fine.
SHRIRAM NENE: I really--
you know, I need, like,
karaoke and all the
other stuff to begin--
AMIT SINGHAL: Oh,
we can give you.
Dinga-dong-ding.
SHRIRAM NENE: [SINGING HINDI]
MADHURI DIXIT NENE:
[SINGING HINDI]
AMIT SINGHAL: All
right, guys, join me
in thanking Madhuri and Ram
for gracing us at Google today.
MADHURI DIXIT-NENE:
Thank you, so much.
Thank you, all of you.
SHRIRAM NENE: An
absolute pleasure.
Thank you.